on behalf of all of us at et Canada and
it's not much it's just it's just it's a
joke really it's you got to read what's
on the flag though guilt-free bread I'll
take it to the bank I looked in I
thought it was a glazed doughnut and I
thought yes I can cop it up now
please don't end up in Canada well
that's our thing they don't it well I
wouldn't okay there he goes
it's a couple weeks old no it's good
it's okay okay that's good we have to
explain to the viewers now why we think
this is funny a lot of these in my life
maybe more than you'd think but there's
certain beers of my life would they
would certainly none of that bread bread
bread carbs and bread no bagels Donuts
because of this roll yeah but you know
every time I kind of hear that coming
out of my mouth I hear some guy watching
TV going hang on a sec so they want you
to play Wolverine and they're gonna give
you a trainer and they're gonna get you
into the best shape of your life and
you're gonna get paid for it yeah not
sinning this is not a sob story you can
have a drink by the way because I see
it's it's stuck back there it's flowers
old like I said thank you buddy um after
all these years of playing this amazing
iconic character what is it what has it
meant to you a lot I mean I love this
character I love the fans yeah I had
never heard of x-men when I got the part
so it's been an education for me but I
feel there's the first film I did in
America and now it's 17 years later it
has been the actual spine of my career
it's allowed me to do a lot of other
stuff it's launched really my career so
I owe everything to it I am really
grateful and proud to have played the
role and when I came to this movie I was
like okay I could only make this movie
if I knew it was the last one because
the stakes were high this is like a love
letter to the fans
and everything I've learned of the
character from playing in and reading
the comics is in this movie no doubt
you're a veteran on Broadway
it's award season our other buddy Ryan
Gosling and Emma do a fantastic job in
la-la land can you rate their the
performances they're dancing they're
phenomenal yeah it's so good and I'm so
proud also I mean both of them I was
about to move on to something but I
watched that movie I love that director
Damien I thought what I did is
extraordinary I know what it takes to
pull that off but to pull off in an
eight-minute scene and a song and dance
you know is incredible the pressure on
them that lied in the background the
pink light I've since found out they'd
shot her over two nights so they had to
takes a day for two days I mean high
high pressure and what they did they did
it with such panache and ease and I'm so
proud of just an event you are riding on
the greatest showman who just got
nominated for two Oscars so it's all
good it's good maybe the musicals back I
love it